une fête incroyable la france à
l'unisson des bleus d'aimé jacquet des
centaines de milliers de personnes une
fois de plus sur les champs elysées pour
assister au triomphe des tricolores
premier champion du monde français de
l'histoire en football au sel ou au sol
ont réussi là où avait été chaud et les
copains de copains où la bande à platini
3 0 face au brésil les zidane djorkaeff
dessailly blanc petit les autres n'ont
même pas pu arriver jusqu'à l'arc de
triomphe tant la foule était compacte
madame monsieur bonsoir près de deux
heures d'une remontée triomphale des
champs-elysées 600000 personnes
attendaient les bleus cet après-midi sur
la plus belle avenue du monde les bleus
et leur entraîneur aimé jacquet pour un
triomphe jamais vu et qui n'a même pas
pu se terminer sous 10 et sur la place
de l'étoile il y avait trop de monde les
malaises dans la foule et les
ordinateurs ont préféré écourter le
trajet le récit de pascal golomer et
jean paul chaussée ils s'étaient donné
rendez vous en cette belle après-midi
d'été sur les champs elysées et quel
rendez vous
un moment exceptionnel un de plus
d'un côté les joueurs de l'équipe de
france voulait montrer à leur public
cette coupe du monde dont ils ne peuvent
plus se séparer de l'autre le public
ces dizaines de milliers de supporters
cinq cent mille six cent mille peut-être
de tous âges de toutes races voulait
dire merci aux bleus merci à zizou à
m'aimer et à tous les autres
l'autobus à impériale noyait dans la
foule n'avancent plus guère et l'arc de
triomphe est encore loin mais qu'importe
sourirait main tendue la victoire est si
belle à partager
oublié le petit quart des notes et les
consignes technico tactique
aimé jacquet savoure l'instant et il
laisse à ses joueurs le soin de veiller
sur la coupe
il peut leur faire confiance
tout le monde se dit merci tout le monde
se dit bravo et à la prochaine fois plus
question de se séparer
c'est une belle histoire d'amour entre
22 joueurs de football
perché sur un autobus et le peuple de
france rassemblés sur une avenue
une histoire qui ne fait que commencer
espérons le
avec la fameuse bise six cent mille
personnes sur selon les chiffres
officiels de la préfecture de police
plus d'un million hier soir sur les
champs la france n'en finit pas de fêter
ses bleus meilleur joueur du monde pour
la première fois de leur histoire chacun
un petit être dans une ambiance de joie
et de bonne humeur parce qu'elle nous
c'est bon et harry potter il y a des
jours comme ça où la foule décide de
prendre un bain de foule
c'est un peu comme si les supporters
n'avaient pas quitté les champs elysées
depuis le sacre de leur idole
bien sûr ils sont venus voir les joueurs
mais finalement après sa nuit folle le
peuple de paris et son propre héros
et des joueurs après deux heures
d'attentes au soleil ils ne verront de
toute façon qu'un petit bout de tête un
tout petit moment parfois au prix de
beaucoup d'efforts alors lancé laurent
blanc qui loupe et c'est la première
fois sur le bus on voit pas grand chose
en fait ouais il a brandi la la force du
collectif comme disent les sportifs se
traduit aussi à l'applaudimètre mais qui
donc est leur préféré et comme
d'habitude c'est aux anciens de donner
la leçon de mathématiques modernes et un
et deux et trois
simple comme une victoire en coupe du
monde dunga
le milieu de terrain des brésiliens a
dit des supporters français qui sont des
poètes
peut-être at-il raison
la première mois nourrit toujours
l'écoulement des couleurs pas
il y à une heure ils ont quitté
progressivement l'arc de leur tri ont
presque à regret à chacun d'entre eux
maintenant de vérifier si la grande
histoire du foot a changé la leur à eux
d'écrire leur propre bonheur
alors pascal que le maire vous êtes sur
les champs elysées ce qui nous fait
incroyable pour l'équipe de france une
rude journée pour les joueurs qui ne
sont pas au bout de leurs peines et de
leur plaisir je crois ça fait la journée
n'est pas encore terminée pour les bleus
qui ont déjà défilé ici plus de deux
heures sur les champs elysées ils vont
revenir sur les champs elysées mais pour
une soirée privée au lido soirée avec
repas et spectacle une faille qui
devrait débuter vers 21h30
l'information n'a rien de confidentiel
puisque ils sont plusieurs centaines de
supporters à les attendre à l'entrée du
lido les joueurs ne sont pas encore là
parce qu'il pose malgré tout leur
laisser le temps de troquer le
survêtement pour la tenue de soirée
alors après cette soirée
eh bien les joueurs ne seront toujours
pas en vacances puisque demain c'est le
14 juillet et les joueurs sont attendus
pour la traditionnelle garden party à
l'elysée jacques chirac mais attendent
de pied ferme
ils seront sans nul doute les grandes
vedettes une nouvelle fois de cette
journée merci parce qu'elle est pure où
effectivement il ya beaucoup de moi on
sait pas comment ils vont réussir à
rentrer dans le dans le lido les joueurs
la journée des bleus yann lavoix vous le
disais tout à l'heure est loin d'être
terminée elle avait commencé ce matin
dès la sortie du centre mitic de
clairefontaine la retraite des bleus
là où se sont succédé les entraînements
et les périodes de repos christelle
bertrand et laurent hamida ont suivi
l'équipe de france toute cette journée
si vous voulez savoir où se trouve
l'équipe de france vous n'avez qu'à
suivre les banderoles
ce matin elle a commencé par la
fédération française de football les
traits sont un peu tirés le sommeil ils
y penseront plus tard c'est à dire j'ai
fait j'ai fait la fête avec la folie
était à clairefontaine fiers comme des
champions du monde ils chérissent leur
couper la partage avec le public
la fête a commencé dans le car 70
kilomètres d'échauffement avant le
bouquet final
zidane est passé de meneur de jeu à
meneur de revue
sur le chemin même les feux rouge vire
au bleu
les supporters veulent montrer leur
amour les joueurs leur ont donné tant de
bonheur des milliers de personnes
ouvrent la route aux champions du monde
on se croirait sur une étape du tour de
france acclamé les joueurs font un
dernier petit coucou avant d'aller
dormir un peu certains n'ont pas dormi
du tout sous la pluie ils ont attendu 10
heures ce matin pour voir passer
l'équipe dans l'autre sens une dernière
fois
mais la fête n'est pas finie on essaie
vais l'apprécier du mieux possible
mais hier soir on s'en est pas trop
rendu compte belge en a fêté ses un
train prépare maintenant on va on se
retrouve encore entre nous et pour en
profiter un petit peu avec tous partager
une victoire ça se fait forcément sur
les champs-elysées les joueurs se sont
installés sur un bus à impériale
tout le monde se tient au courant de la
suite des événements avant de remonter
la plus belle avenue du monde
ils l'ont bien mérité hazard touré
retrouver maintenant yann lavoix qui a
suivi l'équipe de france pendant tout ce
mondial il ya bien sûr un héros dans
cette coupe du monde c'est aimé jacquet
alias mémé critiqué hier et adulé
aujourd'hui
eh bien oui nous nous sommes avec aimé
jacquet et mais on vient de vous voir
sur les champs-elysées est-ce que ça a
été la plus belle ou la plus longue
journée de vote vis à la plus forte
parce que tous ces gens qui viennent
vous remercier qui sont chaleureux
heureux qu'ils aient changé
plein de ou un petit signe de la main
c'est parfois je dirais réconfortant et
ça nous ça nous ça nous touche
profondément
on les voit tout cela derrière vous vous
allez rester amis c'est le terme jusqu'à
jusqu'à demain de votre vie l exercice
alternée on a tellement de complicité ou
non tellement de temps à passer ensemble
on a tellement échanger on a tellement
travaillé on a tellement souffert on a
tellement été aux ensembles que cette
page que nous venons de tourner restera
à jamais gravé dans nos mémoires et on
n'oublie jamais personne al'inverse
l'équipe brésilienne on la disait miné
de l'intérieur par des clans et c est ce
que ça ça peut
ça a pu faire la différence dans le jeu
ce match moi j'ai pas senti qu'elle
était miné c'est une équipe qui n'a
peut-être pas pu jouer son bord son
meilleur football qui a peut-être pas pu
dans ce match de finale parce que a été
redoutable 1 dans le match
c'est un final peut-être qu'elle ne
s'attendait pas une équipe de france aux
ti aussi présente aussi sérieux et aussi
performante
je crois que là-dessus nous avons
peut-être réalisé une des plus belles
prestations de notre football
à chaque fois vous nous avez surpris 1
sur les sept match toutes manières jouit
la qualité et puis comme je vous l'avais
dit annoncé ans j'ai utilisé tous les
moyens et tous les toutes les forces de
cette équipe de france je sais que votre
rêve c'est d'emmener la coupe à sail
sous couzan votre village natal est ce
que vous allez le faire et quand où et
on le fera mais un peu plus tard parce
que en ce moment j'ai beaucoup de
travail
chose promise chose due une dernière
chose vendredi on connaîtra le nom de
votre successeur à la tête de l'équipe
de france je peux vous demander qui vous
souhaiteriez voir parce que vous
répondriez pas mais vous qu'est ce que
vous allez faire maintenant moi je vais
retourner à la direction nationale à la
disposition du football de masse et
retrouver mon poste d'entraîneur
national on en prendra plaisir à vous
revoir et merci pour tous ces beaux
moments de bonheur que vous nous avez
apporté tout au long de cette coupe du
monde merci merci à vous alors nous vous
retrouvons maintenant il ya de la voir
en direct cette fois puisque ces propos
d'enregistrer quelques instants avec
aimé jacquet et cette fois ci le bus de
l'équipe de france est sur le point de
partir c'est ça oui vous allez le
découvrir derrière moi on aperçoit même
là par la la la coupe du monde bien sûr
en tête devant devant le carreau en fait
les joueurs ont les des yeux grands
comme ça ils ont les yeux tout rouges
ils n'ont pas beaucoup dormi
alors il y en a quelques-uns qui sont
déjà partis en menée par les hommes du
raid en voiture avec leurs épouses dans
les hôtels proches
d'ici on va pas les citer pour se
changer pour mettre une tenue un petit
peu plus correct parce que la soirée au
lido va être très certainement un peu un
peu un peu chaude donc certains sont
dans le bus là d'autres vont se rendre
directement lido c'est un petit peu
l'anarchie
la seule chose qui compte vraiment c'est
qu'ils se retrouvent là bas pour faire
la fête alors dans le bus là on a vu
charbonnier il ya guivarc'h qui a aimé
jacquet puisqu'il vient juste de nous
quitter
donc ça va être la grande fête il ya en
soirée chaude au lido c'est quand même
en smoking sait comment alors vous dites
une tenue spéciale
eh bien écoutez je n'en sais rien mais a
priori ces dames qui ont d'abord passé
une journée assez épuisant parce que
vous savez qu'elle était dans le bus
mais à l'étagé inférieur donc on ne les
voyait pas mais elles ont quand même
passé une après midi très très chaude ce
qui fait quand même qu'on les a arrêtés
dans le bois de boulogne pour qu'elle
aille prendre un petit peu l'air à
l'issue de la remontée des
champs-elysées
ces dames souhaitais changer pour aller
au lido ce que l'on peut comprendre
quand même tout à fait il ya donc ces
messieurs qui sont en saharienne ont
aussi envie de m'étaler et voilà et
alors eux ils viennent on parlait tout à
l'heure mais on va y revenir avec un
plaisir on parlait tout à l'heure des
critiques dont aimé jacquet a été
l'objet avant la coupe du monde il a des
critiques qu'il a assez mal vécu des a
même vécu douloureusement
le paradoxe est que le journal l'équipe
qui était le plus virulent à son égard a
battu aujourd'hui tous ses records de
tirage mais pour aimé jacquet hier
c'était l'heure de la revanche
visseyrias et roger motte
aimé jacquet tient entre ses mains la
plus belle des revanches
après le match alors que 80 mille
personnes scandent son nom
le sélectionneur de l'équipe de france
règle ses comptes à chaud et trahi par
des journaux tout au long des années et
la france elle avait une grande équipe
de france qu'elle avait des grands
joueurs et défendent l maillot français
aujourd'hui vous n'avez pas envie de
pardonner
non je pardonnerai jamais jamais je
parle bien d'être au coup qui s'adresse
directement au quotidien sportif
l'équipe accusé levé vous bien sûr on
s'est senti visé puisque la nommément
c'était notre journal qui est
aujourd'hui je dirais le sol assumait ce
que plein de gens les ont écrits il ya
deux mois il faut assumer on s'est
trompé fois ci mais vous faut dire aimé
jacquet bravo c'est bourré vous avez eu
raison
l'équipe fait aujourd'hui son mea culpa
on peut y lire en première page
nous avons de formidablement belle
raison de reconnaître que la méthode
jacquet a payé mais les relations entre
le sélectionneur français une partie de
la presse n'ont jamais été très simple
austère peu médiatique
aimé jacquet a eu du mal avant la coupe
du monde à faire passer son message des
matches de préparation parfois poussif
comme ici face à la russie et voilà que
l'on mette en doute les capacités du
groupe france a gagné la coupe du monde
suscitant la colère du sélectionneur on
ne bafouent par les gens qui travaillent
cette eau jamais le 6 mai dernier alors
qu'aimé jacquet tarder à divulguer la
liste des 22
l'équipe écrit je vous avoue que les
événements m'ont convaincu que jacquet
n'était décidément pas l'homme de la
situation
on peut regretter quoi on peut regretter
de ne pas avoir vu qu'au fond d'aimé
jacquet y avait une lumière qu'à ce
moment là personne à vue et puis bah oui
on peut regretter ça quelle que soit la
volonté du journal l'équipe d'enterrer
la hache de guerre
cette polémique risque de peser encore
longtemps dans le monde du football
français et dans son village de
sail-sous-couzan près de saint-etienne
on n'a bien sûr pas perdre une seule
minute de la finale c'est là que sont
ses amis toujours là qu'aimé jacquet a
grandi jouer au foot et travailler à
l'usiné toute proche de st chamond
son cap2 fraser en poche reportage de
benoît gratte gadret et de thierry
simonet le visage d'aimé jacquet dressée
comme emblème de sail-sous-couzan ils
étaient plusieurs milliers cette nuit
massés sur la place du village pour
fêter la victoire de l'enfant du pays
les français ont la gagne est installé à
la tempe l'honneur un petit écran pour
une grande foule
qu'importe l'essentiel était de vivre
ensemble les exploits de la france
même exaltation café du village
l'établissement failli chavirer dont la
bande à mémé plus certaine de gagner
ils sont les amis des fidèles d'aimé
jacquet ancien joueur comme lui de
l'équipe locale en le voyant
qu'est ce que vous avez ressenti polluer
ni lui ils étaient contents ils ont
pleuré mais avec du caractère
puis s'est jamais démobilisé devant les
critiques par sa tenue son accent sa
mort elle fait un peu il avait la tête
haute et ressort premièrement
sail-sous-couzan attend désormais son
héros aimé jacquet leur a promis il
reviendra bientôt pays avec la coupe
alors l'autre héros de la journée même
s'il n'aime pas trop qu'on dise ça c'est
bien sûr zizou zinédine zidane quand on
lui pose la question il répond toujours
que ce sont les 22 de l'équipe de france
et leur entraîneur aimé jacquet qui sont
les héros de la fête et non pas tel ou
tel joueur en particulier
il n'empêche du côté de marseille on
sait bien que zizou est un enfant du
pays de l'immigration et des quartiers
défavorisés et que c'est bien lui qui a
marqué les deux premiers buts de la tête
en finale
vincent nguyen et caroline marie au bar
de l'eau fraîche à certaines il faisait
soif cet après midi à la télé la france
défilé sur les champs et avec elle
zidane que tout le monde a connu ici
loïc le patron était son entraîneur en
minimes naines et yannick les membres de
la bande
yazid prononcer là dessus on aimerait
que quatre minutes parce que zidane a
passé cinq ans dans le petit club du
village c'était un gamin mais déjà il
était le meilleur
déjà tout le monde l'apprécié
boutin d'un bonheur dans le bon sens
mais il avait énormément de respect pour
les personnes âgées
on venait le chercher dans sa cité de
castellane trois fois par semaine pour
l'entraînement sur le stade municipal
il faisait de mire à vous devez vous
inscrire
tout ceci le groupe parce que c'était
l'exemple à suivre pour les autres
tout le monde voulait arriver à soyaux
il était largement tiré lowy savez c'est
non on va nous demander contre un gars
qui sont ici que certaines à castellane
certes m
lorsqu'on a eu comme à tirer l'oreille
qu'elle a bousculé graphique l'émotion
de l'entraîneur est partagé par toute la
castellanos dit d'anzhi joui acide le
footballeur est symbole d'espoir
désormais c'est à nous c'est de leur
disons michael owen parce que la
castellane
malgré tout ce qu'on dit on a quand même
un champion 1 on n'est pas tendre à
septèmes comme à la castellane les amis
de zizou son fier et comblé ce qu'ils
aimeraient maintenant c'est une passe
les voir juste un instant pour lui dire
merci
et il a dit qu'il y passerait d'ailleurs
alors pour le plaisir heureusement
maintenant sur le match d'hier cette
finale historique remportée 3-0 contre
le brésil 2 buts donc de zidane et un
troisième d'emmanuel petit à la dernière
minute un score de rêve devenu une
réalité françois partout
c'est un obscur objet du désir un truc
un peu informe avec une houle en or pas
forcément joli et pour 22 garçons en
bleu et quelques millions d'autres c'est
l'objet le plus précieux le plus
envoûtant le plus séduisant de la terre
c'est le graal la coupe du monde qui
donne envie d'embrasser tout ce qui est
rond et lisse et qui porte chance
les bisous obsession de france est fou
de bonheur et de joie de jouer les
bisous de zizou surtout quand il a
marqué
2 0 à la mi temps deux coups de tête de
zinedine zidane
et dire que ça aurait pu faire plus par
deux fois en effet stéphane guivarc'h
trop polis refuse un cadeau venu du
brésil
en finale de la coupe du monde c'est dur
d'avoir du sang froid
christophe dugarry qui remplace le
breton manque un but tout fait
lui aussi est les champions du monde ils
font quoi me direz vous comme d'habitude
il compte sur ronaldo le voilà qui sort
de sa boîte à l'heure de jeu ça tombe
bien
barthez aussi bref avec des français qui
marque des buts et des brésiliens qui ne
remarquent pas tout va bien tout va bien
jusqu'à cette 68ème minute où tout à
coup tout va mal marcel desailly est en
retard sur café faute deuxième carton
jaune ça fait carton rouge dehors à 10
sans son stoppeur infranchissable et
déjà sans laurent blanc les minutes vont
être longues jusqu'à la 90e la 90e c'est
presque la fin
et vieira glisse la balle appétit 3 0
cette fois plus de raison d'avoir peur
les français tous les français sont
champions du monde champions du monde
championne du monde champion
extraordinaire non combien rêve
on vient avec qui j'ai pas près de
s'arrêter on est au nom dans ses pas on
voit là je touche pas je touche pas les
pieds je suis chaud au sud
pas parce qu'on sent supérieur parce que
il ya quelque chose d un courant qui
nous porte et on n'a qu'une hâte après
avoir touché la couv après l'avoir en
match aller vers les gens aujourd'hui et
pendant que les deux entraîneurs
fraternisent les joueurs réalisent toute
la détresse du brésil coulent sur les
joues de leonardo et de ses amis
dépossédés de leur coupe du monde
mais voilà à la fin il fallait bien
numéro un désormais c'est le numéro de
barthez et de ses copains
et le match à peine terminée des
centaines et des centaines de milliers
de supporters ont envahi les champs
elysées une fête comme la france n'en
avait pas connu ditto depuis la
libération
une communion totale de tout un peuple
olivier caroff et a vécu là jamais l'arc
de triomphe n'aura si bien porté son nom
sous l'oeil des géants de l'équipe de
france
un million et demi de personnes hier
soir sur les champs elysées
toute une nuit blanche pour voir la vie
en bleu
le rêve est devenu réalité et les
brésiliens qui s'appelait fait que ça
fait les ont accompagnés pour danser on
a même trouvé mieux que la samba
une telle marée humaine c'était du
jamais vu depuis près d'un demi-siècle
le même drapeau pour tous et à chacun
son rire
de toute façon personne n'a été oublié
même pas la mascotte surtout pas
l'entraîneur
mais dès les premières minutes de fait
paris s'était déjà choisi un libérateur
et un seul accident est venu ternir la
fête à un accident provoqué par une
automobiliste visiblement paniquée de
voir sa voiture secoué de joie par des
supporters
elle a foncé dans la foule près de 150
personnes ont dû être examinée dans
différents hôpitaux parisiens
onze ont été sérieusement blessé mais la
vie d'aucune d'entre elles mais ce soir
menacée l'automobiliste une institutrice
de 44 ans fragile psychologiquement a
été conduite à l'infirmerie
psychiatrique de la préfecture de police
et puis d'autres incidents de moindre
gravité se sont produits dans
différentes villes de france à chaque
fois ou presque il s'agissait
l'automobiliste ivre ou de supporters
qui sont tombées de voiture en marche
mais dans l'ensemble la nuit dernière a
été une nuit de fête à marseille lille
ou encore montpellier juliette pour la
victoire et c'est toute la france qui
chavire
a bordeaux ils sont plus de 40 milles et
puis j'aime le poney vote entendu la
gauche attend des sens
j'ai repensé à gagner la même furie sur
la grande place de lille près de vingt
mille personnes
et c'est en couleurs que chacun exprime
sa fierté de la victoire
a lyon le cortège est menée tambour
battant sans égard pour les oreilles
sensibles
ici on claironne facilement sa joie et
on s'amuse de toutes les façons
possibles
là
il n'y a pas d'âge pour exprimer ses
passions
deux buts de zizou et voilà marseille sa
ville natale qui explose de fierté
installé sur la plage du prado
soixante mille supporteurs un record
d'affluence depuis le début du mondial
nefiach de teint frais chez moi nous
tous avec toi déjà trop dit jouer un
essayage de à chacun ses héros ici en
nouvelle calédonie comme dans la plupart
des départements et territoires
d'outre-mer
la fête est encore la fête et avec
toujours toujours le même refrain
regarde maintenant vers les grands
perdants de la soirée les brésiliens
selon la presse au brésil la seleçao a
subi la pire défaite de son histoire est
bien sûr au critique les choix de
l'entraîneur zagallo et la piètre
performance de ronaldo sur place au
brésil christophe duchiron et france
vaillante des gros nuages noirs et une
mer agitée à rio de janeiro ce matin le
temps était encore à l'orage pas grand
monde sur la plage on démonte les
échafaudages bref un vrai climat de
tristesse en matière de football on peut
dire sans exagérer que les brésiliennes
que la victoire
alors quand ils perdent une finale de
coupe du monde forcément ça fait mal je
pense que zagallo l'entraîneur n'était
pas aux commandes de la sélection
c'était un simple pion il le dirige est
rien et revenait d'ailleurs ce qui avait
le pouvoir c'était les sponsors et
surtout ricard nos déchets ras le
président de la fédération pour avoir
une idée de la déception il suffit de
lire les gros titres de la presse du
jour la france massacre le brésil pour
la coupe la france écartent le rêve d'un
cinquième titre fiasco en finale piasco
brésiliens quatre ans il va bien leur
falloir quatre ans les brésiliens pour
se refaire une santé
parce qu'il ya soir même les plus
pessimistes des pronostiqueurs n'aurait
pas imaginé telle déroute
ils en ont versé des larmes pendant la
rencontre des grosses larmes de
supporters qui n'en croyaient pas leurs
yeux
encore que certains ça comme toujours au
mieux du malheur que d'autres
non non il n'y a pas de tristesse au
brésil qu'il est presque à la fin
les brésiliennes sont jamais triste en
2002 on sera champion pour la cinquième
fois c'était comme chez michou mais à
copacabana
une petite représentation un petit
spectacle sur la plage pour remonter le
moral aux supporters
il en avait besoin
alors christophe duchiron vous êtes au
brésil à rio les brésiliens ne sont donc
pas pour la cinquième fois champion du
monde et cette défaite intervient dans
un climat politique assez agitée
christophe écouter ce qu'on peut dire
c'est que ce matin pour le brésil c'est
un petit peu le retour à la réalité des
choses pendant un mois de coupe du monde
et bien les brésiliens rêver d'un
cinquième titre
mais après la défaite d'hier soir eh
bien on ne rêve plus en cas de victoire
le président cardozo aurait sans doute
accordé un jour de congé ce lundi un
jour férié mais au lieu de cela et bien
le brésil ce grand pays de 150 millions
d'habitants s'est réveillée avec sa tête
des mauvais jours leur maintenance qui
va un petit peu occupé l'esprit des gens
ici au brésil et bien ce sont les
élections présidentielles dont la
campagne électorale vient de débuter
est ce qu'il faut savoir est bien c'est
que pendant la coupe du monde tous les
candidats ici soutenait officiellement
l'équipe du brésil
le supporters est un électeur sauf qu'en
l'occurrence on voit mal quelles parties
vont pouvoir tirer les candidats delà de
la défaite de leurs de leur équipe
alors ce que l'on peut dire aussi c'est
que les brésiliens sont las et fatigué
par la politique et les promesses non
tenues
encore que dans ce domaine et bien un
ronaldo et les siens ont profondément
déçus eux aussi en perdant hier la
finale de la coupe du monde
merci christophe les images fortes de
cette coupe du monde se bouscule déjà
dans nos têtes que ce soit les images
dramatiques de ces hooligans allemands
en laissant pour mort le maréchal des
logis daniel nivel ou bien encore celle
de l'élimination pathétique des
marocains après un match fantastique
thierry kurt et les artistes ont été les
seigneurs de cette coupe du monde
debout assis à terre nous ont donné le
tournis aux défenseurs zidane le
français want évoque les mexicains
okocha nigérian
une liste parfaitement arbitraire temps
le choix est difficile
tout aussi difficile le palmarès des
plus beau but pire son cas le cameroun
est parti de son propre camp
l'instantané de sunday oliseh
chronométré à 115 kilomètres-heure le
but de thierry henry une passe dé 80 m
de fabien barthez
l'incroyable contrôle de l'avant centre
néerlandais bert quand en pleine course
le culot jusqu'à l'homme dowell le plus
jeune attaquant de l'histoire de la
sélection anglaise 18 ans
et il marque
la détermination la technique d'hadji le
marocain qui n'arrivera pas à qualifier
son pays pour les huitièmes de finale
la seule chose sur laquelle tout le
monde s'accorde l'arbitrage a gâché les
chances du cameroun
plus tu refuses et sans raison il a bien
aidé l'italie qui égalise sur un penalty
imaginaire humains provoqués
sans évoquer un festival de cartons
rouges toutefois selon les consignes et
stan plein à craquer un public fervent
hélas il eut à marseille à certains
angleterre tunisie les hooligans
resteront la tâche noire de ce mondial
a lens surtout pascale nivelle gendarmes
agressé par un groupe de hooligans
allemands et toujours ce soir dans le
coma
la deuxième phase de la coupe du monde
débute pour les français par un voyage
au bout de la hongroise
jusqu'où but en or de laurent blanc
la france est en quarts de finale contre
l'italie le match et des frères ennemis
un tiers des 22 joueurs français jouent
sur la péninsule
il faudra attendre le dernier tir du
dernier italien pour respirer les
barthez qui ne comprend pas pas tout de
suite
la france est en demi finale
c'est alors le temps des révélations les
arrières de vielles attaque pour cette
équipe se découvre un nouveau buteur 10
coups de pied magique le mignan kurram
deux buts qui propulsent et le loup dans
le rêve la finale
la france à l'époque rencontrer le
brésil et son phénomène en l2 mais voilà
mais joueur le mieux payé du monde a peu
marqué trop surveillé il s'est contenté
leur rôle d'ultime passeur durant les
sept matches du brésil
et voilà voilà comment au bout du
parcours des français parfaitement
réveillé se sont mis à rêver les yeux
grands ouverts
et partout dans le monde on a souligné
la belle image que la france avait donné
d'elle-même à l'occasion de ce mondial
bien sûr il y a eu le scandale des
billets virtuels mais dans l'ensemble
l'organisation a été exemplaire et
michel platini aujourd'hui peut se dire
heureux mais content que ce soit fini
après 34 jours de compétition sébastien
guibert et françois dagnaud on remballe
la fête est finie
le centre de presse de la coupe du monde
à paris se vide peu à peu de ses treize
mille journalistes et de ses bénévoles
convaincus d'avoir vécu ici près de six
semaines exceptionnelles bien continuer
la coupe du monde encore plus longtemps
l'ambiance les rapports qu'on avec les
gens tous les journalistes puis avec les
volontaires on a informé petite famille
et ça c'était vraiment formidable
les membres du comité français
d'organisation se sont félicités du
déroulement des matchs dans les tribunes
des stades remplis à ras bord de
supporter enchanté pas le moindre
incident dans les gradins jugée
confortable et conviviaux le cf os
satisfait également de l'accueil réservé
par les dix villes organisatrices aux
équipes et à leurs supporters
succès total pas tout à fait cette coupe
du monde restera celle du scandale de la
billetterie des milliers de japonais
brésilien vénézuélien entre autres
auront payé des billets voyages et
hôtels compris sans jamais en voir la
couleur la police
saisis de nombreuses plaintes écarte
pour le moment toute responsabilité du c
est faux c'est pourtant lui qui a agréé
des tours opérators comme prague sport
international soupçonné d'escroquerie et
l'union européenne s'apprête à exprimer
publiquement ses critiques au cf os sur
un système de ventes jugée contraire aux
règles de la concurrence et jean pierre
chevènement aujourd'hui à parler de
victoire de la france en hommage aux
forces de l'ordre qui ont assuré la
sécurité de ce mondial
je vous le disais le monde entier
saluent la parfaite coordination de la
france et la victoire de son équipe défi
station a dressé entre autres par boris
elstine tony blair ou encore bill
clinton qui se dit émerveillé par la
victoire française avec money devant la
maison de france à berlin
la célèbre avenue le cours furent
steendam avait des airs de champs
elysées hier soir après le triomphe
tricolore
les français mais aussi les allemands
venus partager un peu plus tôt en
connaisseur les grands moments de cette
finale une finale pour laquelle certains
avaient eu du nez
à 3-0 parce que on est vraiment très
très fort en défense à washington
l'ambassade de france était hier le lieu
de ralliement de tous les amateurs de
ballon rond français au coup de sifflet
final il faisait encore jour aux états
unis pas encore à pékin où seuls les
vrais passionnés avaient décidé de
passer une nuit blanche pour l'amour du
football
ici on connaît les brésiliens on les
apprécie il partait favori mais dans
cette nuit de chine
les pékinois ont découvert de nouvelles
idoles monstre que les dames il est
vraiment génial vraiment génial moi je
suis pour la france 2 clics
je trouve qu'ils ont un esprit d'équipé
extraordinaire et pour preuve que ce
n'est pas parce qu'on est loin et peu
nombreux qu'on ne peut pas faire parler
de soi c'est sur une plage de sydney en
australie que les supporters français
ont déployé ce gigantesque drapeau hier
soir même les français du bout du monde
était derrière les bleus et en retour
même quelques instants voir pascal
golomer qui se trouvent toujours sur les
champs-elysées je crois prête pas loin
du lido où se trouve maintenant l'équipe
de france pascal donc il n'ya pas de
monde sur l'avenue elle-même en revanche
du monde près du lido je crois et puis
un bilan assez fantastique de cette
coupe du monde avec une réussite à la
fois sur le plan des terrains qui ont
été remplies et puis sur le plan des
buts il ya eu un maximum de buts dans
cette coupe du monde
voilà tout cas cette image est derrière
moi du lido envahi en tout cas à
l'extérieur sur les trottoirs envahis
par la foule
une nouvelle fois ça résume bien cette
coupe du monde avec un engouement
populaire qu'on ne pouvait imaginer en
tout début de coupe du monde il y a
encore des centaines de personnes qui
sont ici le concert de klaxons a repris
comme il avait débuté hier avant même le
match avant même la finale
eh bien les gens sont encore là attendre
l'équipe de france qui n'est pas arrivé
yann lavoix vous disais tout à l'heure
les joueurs ont pu peut-être un petit
peu de retard ils veulent se changer de
prendre leur temps et bien les
spectateurs le public lui attend et il
veut être là pour les remercier pour les
encourager une nouvelle fois dans cette
voie si cet engouement va durer mais en
tout cas pour l'instant
à chaque apparition de l'équipe de
france à chaque apparition d'un joueur
l'équipe de france eh bien c'est la même
folie le même délire on les attend d'un
moment à l'autre les forces de
l'opposition
ça promet d'être encore très très chaud
ce soir sur les champs elysées et pascal
un engouement qui vaut aussi bien pour
les femmes que pour les hommes parce que
tout les records d'audience bien sûr ont
été battus pour ses sept finales et
selon les chiffres il y avait quasiment
autant de femmes que d'hommes devant
leur poste
et puis une performance à souligner
celle des postes qu'ils ont sortis dans
la nuit un talent pour la coupe bon
matin devront évidemment comme un ballon
de foot et que vous trouverez au même
prix que les autres à 3 francs et puis
une performance identique à la monnaie
de paris où les ateliers ont frappé
pendant la nuit une pièce d'argent
souvenirs qui coûte 150 de francs le
reste de l'actualité c'est d'abord
l'irlande du nord les orangistes ont
maintenu leur marche en dépit d'une
meurtrière de trois enfants qui avaient
le tort d'être catholique
seul bémol ils ont accepté de réduire la
taille de leur cortège et de faire taire
leurs chances à reportage à belfast de
jérôme baugnies et patrick que des semis
parade traditionnelle des protestants
d'irlande du nord
ils célèbrent une bataille gagnée par
guillaume d'orange contre les peuples et
yolande à la fin du xviie siècle
depuis les orangistes met un point
d'honneur à défiler à fouler cette terre
défiant la communauté catholique
les cette année la fête est gâchée par
la mort de ces trois gars ont brûlé hier
dans l'incendié de leurs maisons
provoqué d'après la police par un
extrémiste protestants en hommage à ses
enfants
les catholiques ne s'oppose pas par la
force à la traversée de leur quartier ou
préfèrent aujourd'hui une protestation
pacifique les orangistes de leur côté
arrête la musique dans cette rude
ormeaux ce matin ils ont défilé sur des
morts le top down les orangistes se
heurte depuis huit jours à un important
dispositif de sécurité
la procession doit faire demi-tour
frustration chez les protestants nous
faisons cette marche depuis près de 100
ans
avant nous avions des corps il y en a
plus qu aujourd'hui alors nous avons
envie de dire ainsi en fait c'est un
dernier noyau dur d'orange east qui
semblent déterminés à passer ce barrage
qui barre l'accès au quartier catholique
mais chaque jour qui passe augmente les
risques de violences et ce soir la
situation reste très tendue le premier
ministre irlandais écourté sa visite en
france en raison de cette situation en
irlande du nord où l'armée britannique à
désamorcer tout à l'heure une voiture
piégée qui contenait 250 kg d'explosifs
cela près de belfast au sud ouest de
belfast
au japon c'est le premier ministre
hashimoto qui a démissionné après la
cuisante défaite infligée à son parc
dimanche lors des sénatoriales tout est
de ma faute at il dit j'assume la
responsabilité de cette grande défaite
monsieur achim peu pourrait être
remplacé par l'une des fortes
personnalités de son parti l'un de ses
ennemis intimes
monsieur k -o en italie c'est une
nouvelle condamnation pour silvio
berlusconi la troisième le chef de
l'opposition de droite italienne est
condamné à une peine de deux ans et
quatre mois de prison pour financement
illicite du parti socialiste de bettino
craxi mais cette peine n'est pas entre
eux applicable toutes les voies de
recours ne sont pas encore épuisés
en france un mot sur le bac et la cuvée
98 c'est un très bon cru le taux de
réussite atteint 78 8% soit près de
quatre candidats sur cinq
c'est le taux le plus élevé depuis 1968
mais pour d'autres raisons
il y avait au total plus de six cent dix
mille candidats 481 milles 0,88
précisément ont obtenu leur diplôme
le tour de france est la deuxième étape
irlandaise qui n'a pas été une balade
loin s'en faut pour le britannique chris
boardman le maillot jaune a dû
abandonner après une chute
alexandra à kara et nathalie cahet fin
de la balade irlandaise pour le tour de
france après dublin la capitale
les coureurs se sont élancés cet après
midi entrée 10 cortier cork dans le sud
du pays
chris moorman le maillot jaune vainqueur
du prologue a bien entamé l'étape sous
les applaudissements de spectateurs qui
n'aiment pas que le vélo
une étape longue de 106 kilomètres sans
grosse difficulté mais avec un vent
violent
un vent qui provoque des chutes bormann
pris dans un accrochage tombe lourdement
immédiatement il est transféré à
l'hôpital de cork le tour pour lui c'est
fini alors ce que j'ai ramassé il n'est
juste de reprendre connaissance donc il
ya eu un traumatisme crânien avec perte
de connaissance initiale qu'elle était
de durée brad je pense de trois minutes
une chute heureusement sans gravité pour
born man et pour les autres aussi car
aujourd'hui sur le tour il y à une chute
collective extrêmement spectaculaire à
quelques kilomètres de l'arrivée sur le
tour sous le ciel irlandais il ait eu
aussi la belle échappée de seigneurs et
simon mais finalement c'est un sprint
qui a décidé du vainqueur du moura da le
tchèque
excellent à cet exercice ils enlèvent
l'étape devant mc ewen multiplient mais
c'est erik zabel le coéquipier d'ullrich
dans l'équipe beach télécom il s'empare
du maillot jaune
et demain les coureurs seront en france
en bretagne entre roscoff et lorient ni
cantal enquête sur la sphère des
produits dopants du soigneur de l'équipe
festina il a été mis en examen pour
importation en contrebande de
marchandises prohibées et incarcéré à la
maison d'arrêt de loos près de lille
voilà on arrive bientôt à la fin de ce
journal
merci de l'avoir suivi dans un instant
la météo de sophie davant demain à
l'heure de vérité emmanuel vanier
recevra le général bigeard pour le 14
juillet les répétitions ont bien sûr
commencer aujourd'hui c'était la
patrouille de france qui s'ancre est né
à evreux en attendant de survoler paris
demain pour le défilé des images
montrent que à evreux et puis ensuite ce
sera l'intervention officielle et
traditionnelles de jacques chirac bien
sûr que vous pourrez suivre sur france 2
avec arlette chabot et patrick poivre
d'arvor et puis la garden party dont les
invités d'honneur seront bien sûr les
bleus d'aimé jacquet je vous dis bon
soir et je vous laisse donc avec ses
très belles images de la coupe du monde
rassemblés par régis vidal et bruno
colangelo
quand ça met au pas fait
mais ce dans un des hangars
je pouvoir c'est soir de victoire nous
répondez
c'est monsieur est petit
ces pays représentés cette magie époux
c'est beau de voir tout ce monde qui
joue allez allez
afin de se faire aider
attendez
jouer contre nous
marquer
ado
émotion et la base